I remember the heat the dust people go
into the streets and hear all these
sounds of just loud voices and all these
sounds just became so scary and so vivid
and vibrant trucks carrying these
soldiers and black shirts and black
pants carrying guns and grenades on
their belts they were going to create a
brand new society bring cambodia back to
its days of glory they loved us more
than our parents because they were our
protector they were our provider they
were our everything
we were supposed to give back everything
to them but slowly one by one with one
policy after another they take away your
individuality they take away of soul you
believe we are supposedly children of
the Khmer Rouge revolution we were told
we were fearless and we had power they
were teaching us to look at the things
around us as weapons a sip a knife an
axe a rock it was really confusing to
have that message that harm and hurt and
hate was good
this film is through the eyes of a child
and it helps this to not be a
traditional film and no mind of a child
is traditional and boring anyway I
wanted to really know what a child felt
and what they looked at what they
focused on bring the audience into her
mind
you said the five-year-old happy child
become a 9 year old victim of war how
can we not be the most the most
concerned about children at war in every
war the innocent
you
[Music]
you